Труну з тілом Гельмута Коля вносять
до пленарної зали Європейського парламенту.
Університетський оркестр Страсбурга
грає похоронний марш Ґеорґа Фрідріха Генделя.
Приїхали вшанувати пам'ять "канцлера німецької єдності" -
європейські та світові лідери,
нинішні та колишні.
Для багатьох це був справді емоційний момент.
Зі смертю Гельмута Коля ми втратили
велетня повоєнного часу.
Ще під час свого життя він зробив історію.
І він завжди буде частиною цієї історії.
Гельмут Коль дав нам можливість
бути причетним до чогось більшого,
ніж ми самі.
Більшого за наш час при владі.
Більшого за наші кар’єри.
Перед прощальним словом
колишній американський лідер
висловив співчуття вдові Гельмута Коля - Майке Коль-Ріхтер.
Особисто попрощатися з видатним німецьким канцлером
також прибули президент Франції Еммануель Макрон,
президент України Петро Порошенко та багато інших.
Канцлерка Німеччини Анґела Меркель
щиро подякувала своєму наставникові.
Без Гельмута Коля
життя мільйонів людей, які до 1990-го року жили по той бік муру,
було б зовсім іншим. Звичайно ж, і моє життя.
Шановний федеральний канцлере!
У тому, що я тут стою,
ваша роль була вирішальною.
Дякую вам за шанс,
який ви мені надали.
Дякую за шанси,
які ви створили для багатьох інших.
Дякую за все те, що ми,
отримали від вас.
Ви безмежно багато чого досягли.
Спочивайте у спокої.
Це був перший в історії ЄС
загальноєвропейський державний акт
прощання з видатною особою.
Після церемонії у французькому Страсбурзі
труну з тілом Гельмута Коля
урочисто відправили назад до Німеччини,
де колишнього канцлера поховають на кладовищі в містечку Шпаєр.